[Music]
hey everyone I didn't eat here I took a
game to a 20-17 and we saw a pretty cool
indie game that may be reminiscent of
something you may have played it and
loved in the pause hey yeah tiny metal
tiny metal a game very similar to
Advance Wars a game series that used to
be made by intelligent systems that came
out on the Game Boy Advance and then all
but gosh no there were Deus games right
yeah yeah there yeah but after that it
all but vanished
yeah but tiny metal seems to be bringing
it all back and it's coming to
Nintendo's switch in addition to a bunch
of other platform like piece a baseball
that kind of stuff it's got a really
great visual style so it's not a 2d
sprite-based game it is a polygonal game
but everything else is basically the
advanced warriors that you knew I mean
you are moving around a map you've got
soldiers you've got tanks you are also
taking over buildings and you're
upgrading sort of the Arsenal that you
can build to bring into the map yeah
it's been a while since I played
advanced wolves but mechanically the the
system seems almost one-for-one with
advanced walls there were a few extra
things yes the the focused attack what
was a call to local insist the lock-on
system so essentially what you would do
is you would have two units that would
more or less flank an enemy unit and
then they could attack both
simultaneously yeah the enemy would
still get a chance to counter-attack but
you would get two attacks or they're one
so you could wipe them out basically if
you were good enough but you know still
like if you hide in the trees that ups
your defense but if your enemy is hiding
in the trees it also makes it a little
bit more difficult so there's that have
been flow there's also the assault move
which lets you push enemies back yeah so
if they are in the trees you can get
them out and then open them up for the
rest of your turn for other enemies or
for other allies to attack the other
thing with that is that they attack
first so you could get wiped out
potentially correct so we played it on
PC it looks great it plays pretty well
yeah and it's coming out very soon it's
coming on next month
yeah this is something that looks really
good the odd sounds great I love the
sort of voxel effect of the fog of war
right it's got like a very much like a
gridded as you put it box will affect
it's not the typical sort of like
ambiguous space I mean it is ambiguous
but it's really more blocked off and
yeah as you move you sort of uncover
more yeah I mean I'm a huge fan of
strategy of turn-based strategy and
especially after playing rabbits on the
switch I'm looking for more on that
console yeah and it looks like this is
gonna scratch that edge because you're
gonna be long matches as well we played
for about 20 minutes and I feel like we
only uncovered about half the map yeah
yeah so keep an eye out for tiny metal
we're gonna follow this up if you
haven't seen some already during this
video more gameplay and stay tuned for
more coverage from Tokyo Game Show
17
[Music]